bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de kiosques kiosque votre
magazine dédié à la culture sur saint
quentin en yvelines et ses environs tout
de suite les titres de ce mercredi 21
octobre katy blondeau et temps plateau
pour nous parler du travail autour de la
thématique du conte merveilleux
thématiques traitées au travers de deux
expositions proposées à guyancourt
anne sophie moreau chargé de la
communication et des publics au musée
promenade de marie leroy l'ancien vient
nous présenter l'exposition être femme
sous louis xiv du mythe à la réalité
explications sur la condition féminine
de cette époque philippe calandre
proposait ce photomontage d'une venise
imaginaire à l'espace riche de
versailles jusqu'au 8 novembre
ses compositions photographiques résulte
d'une imbrication d'image de la ville
historique de venise et de sa zone
industrielle
c'est donc une émission consacrée aux
très belles expositions du moment
nous démarrons notre émission avec cathy
blondeau responsable du service action
culturelle de la ville de guyancourt
bonsoir et anne sophie moreau chargée
des publics et de la communication au
musée promenade de marley le roi
l'officiel bonsoir soit cathy blondeau
pourquoi avoir choisi le conte
merveilleux comme thématique centrale
des premières expositions et guyancourt
on a imaginé que le comte pouvait parler
aux petits et aux grands tout le monde a
été un enfant et le compte effectivement
peu amené à voyager à rêver et on a
voulu en faire une thématique centrale
sur nos expositions de rentrer à
guyancourt
alors je lisais actuellement sont
présentés deux expositions la première
de l'artiste geneviève penloup à la
médiane et de l'hôtel de ville de bus en
cours jusqu'au 31 octobre
geneviève par l'eau qui est une artiste
connue pour ses projets de bandes
dessinées et de dessins animés pourquoi
avoir fait appel à cet artiste on a fait
appel à genève son loup qui est une
artiste qui comme vous l'avez dit a
travaillé longtemps dans la bande
dessinée et
là la bande dessinée d'un côté et le
dessin animé par dirt excusez moi
effectivement cet artiste travaille
essentiellement autour de la forêt donc
on a voulu faire de la forêt un des
personnage principal du compte c'est
vrai que c'est vraiment un lieu
récurrent dans tous les contes pour
enfants à la forêt maudite la forêt
magique la forêt qui fait peur son
travail s'inspire des cours en habits et
symboliste est ce que vous pourriez nous
dire un mot pour nous expliquer ses
cours en histoire de l'art post
impressionnistes de la fin du 19e siècle
alors effectivement je vais pas vous
faire un cours d'histoire de l'art ce
soir mais effectivement les nabis les
symbolistes sont un courant un post
impressionnistes de la fin du 19e siècle
qui ont été tous les deux inspirés de
paul gauguin
ils sont opposés pour les symbolistes à
la définition même de la réalité
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont envie de montrer
un regard différent pour les nabis eux
s'est également opposée ça se
débarrasser de la contrainte imitative
dans la peinture mais également de
travailler autour des couleurs vives
tous les deux sont empreintes au sacré
alors on voit d'ailleurs à l'image ce
sont des tableaux avec des couleurs très
vives
et justement elle a cherché en fait à
représenter la forêt de façon un peu
onirique est ce qu'on pourrait dire ça
oui effectivement il ya une
représentation onirique de la forêt elle
a eu plusieurs phases décisives dans son
travail autour des arbres principalement
elle a fait d'ailleurs des études y
croire pendant deux ans une université
au travail des lichens exactement
effectivement elle a travaillé autour
des lichens au départ après avoir arrêté
de travailler dans la bande dessinée le
dessin animé puis elle a eu un moment
dans sa vie lors d'une promenade à la
croisée des arbres qui étaient marquées
d'une grande croix rouge
et là ça a été comme un moment phare
pour elle elle a décidé de travailler
autour de ces arbres et on retrouve dans
son travail ces arbres qui sont
empreints effectivement au cachet à la
créativité mais également qui quand on
le découvre sont entourés d'animaux
vraiment il faut s'approcher de sa
pâture pour pouvoir découvrir l'ensemble
de son travail est donc celui la forêt
représentés de façon un peu onirique se
rattache pleinement au thème du conte
merveilleux
anne sophie moreau est ce que le courant
symboliste et d'un courant auquel vous
êtes sensible qui vous parle
alors moi en envoyant quelques images je
trouve que ça fait vraiment rêver donc
j'aurais tendance à dire que le pari est
réussi
ce que j'aime beaucoup c'est qu'on voit
la forêt sous toutes ses facettes
on voyait des images plutôt grise et
noire donc la forêt qui fait peur et en
même temps il ya des colères des
couleurs très flashy
il y avait du vert fluo duros pioche je
trouve que ça attire l'oeil forcément et
du coup ça attire probablement
différents types de public
c'est vrai que ça surprend on s'attend
pas nécessairement à à ses couleurs et
c'est ce qui fait tout l'intérêt de
cette exposition
alors avant de poursuivre avec nos
invités je vous propose une
rétrospective de la 13e édition d'art
manet qui se déroulait ce week-end à la
ferme du manet de montigny le bretonneux
une exposition organisée par le lions
club de montigny les trois villages au
profit de la lutte contre la maladie
d'alzheimer la maltraitance et le
handicap
les 52 artistes réunis pour l'occasion
propose des peintures sculptures ou
photographies d'art simule auront été
récoltés cette année par le lions club
de montigny au profit de la bonne cause
l'association espère recueillir encore
davantage l'an prochain avec une édition
d'arman et internationale nous avons
cinquante deux artistes présents avec un
niveau qui montrent de plus en plus le
public hier était assez assez satisfait
c'est le retour et ce qui est très
encourageant pour nous c'est dès que le
public nous dit effectivement
ça monte de plus en plus ces deux braves
ont alors qu'ati blondeau vous avez
également programmées sur billancourt
une deuxième exposition autour de la
thématique du conte qui s'appelle des
mondes merveilleux là le concept est un
petit peu différente mais pas en avant
un artiste mais une vingtaine exactement
même 21 pour être précis on a vingt
artistes qui exposent est une artiste
qui a fait les illustrations julie
dumont qui a travaillé à l'écriture du
conte avec notre chargée de médiation et
des publics aurélien de maison qui est
venu présenter l'exposition ce vendredi
dernier sur ce même plateau
alors cette exposition peut la retrouver
dans votre salle des expositions
jusqu'au 6 décembre et donc chaque
artiste a travaillé autour d'un lieu
symbolique du compte comme la forêt la
caverne les grottes les palais mais de
quelle façon
alors en fait c'est nous qui avons
sélectionné ces artistes qui étaient
d'univers merveilleux et à travers leurs
oeuvres que l'on a pu sélectionner
nous avons placé entre guillemets ces
artistes dans des lieux qui nous
paraissaient symbolique des comptes donc
effectivement comme vous l'avez souligné
la forêt mais également la caverne de
l'ogre blanc le jardin étrange et enfin
le palais a ensorcelé c'est une
promenade vraiment dans le conte où on
incarne de deux jeunes enfants qui vont
à la découvre et à la découverte de
l'histoire qui a été créé pour cette
exposition qui deviennent un boléro du
coup du conte qui leur est proposée
alors on s'attend à trouver surtout de
la peinture mais pas que également de la
sculpture est un travail autour des
matières qu'est ce qu'on peut voir
également
alors effectivement finalement il n'y a
que très peu de peinture dans
l'exposition même que très peu de
peinture et de d'oeuvre en 2d il ya
beaucoup de sculptures qui sont
représentés dans l'exposition car
effectivement c'est plus facile pour
incarner des personnages quand on voit
ces oeuvres qui sont saisissantes dans
toutes les parties nous proposons
effectivement différentes matières nous
avons autour de la forêt de la matière
autour du bois par exemple des matières
naturelles nous avons également toute
une installation de damian louche
pélissier avec ses petits soldats que je
vous invite à découvrir sur la caverne
de l'ogre blanc nous sommes plutôt
plutôt sur de la pierre mais également
magnifique travail de magnifique travail
de marc touret en papier mâché de l'ogre
le fameux puis également nous avons des
sculptures textiles
nous avons des oiseaux magnifique de
rebecca campo des sculptures en raku et
sur la dernière partie sur le palais
ensorcelé là nous avons de la dentelle
ou de la peinture mais également encore
des sculptures donc tous les styles
d'arts sont presque représenté lors de
cette exposition s'inscrire à bientôt
également dans ce thème du conte
merveilleux
une exposition de clémentine de
chabaneix à partir du 12 novembre
alors là qu'est ce que vous avez voulu
mettre mettre à l'honneur alors comme
pour geneviève penloup nous avons voulu
mettre à l'honneur la forêt autour de ce
personnage principal pour clémentine de
chabaneix nous sommes partis sur la
sculpture la sculpture animalière
clémentine de chabaneix à un univers
effectivement très tim burton donc on
peut retrouver des personnages
principalement féminins masqué de loups
donc vraiment à découvrir à partir du 12
novembre
allam été ni de l'hôtel de ville et on
viendra également y faire un tour
anne sophie moreau vous présenter une
exposition musée promenade de marier le
rôle officiel jusqu'au 14 février 2016
qui est consacrée à la condition
féminine sous louis xiv
c'est un thème rarement évoquée alors
qualité le rôle dévolu à la femme ou dix
septième siècle alors au xviie siècle
une femme se définit par ses fonctions
familiale on attend d'une femme qu'elle
soit d'abord une épouse et ensuite une
mère alors ce qui est aussi important de
noter c'est que quand on devient une
épouse
eh bien on passe de l'autorité de son
père à l'autorité de son mari puisque à
l'époque une femme est toujours de
convaincre considérée comme inférieure à
un homme alors la question qu'on se pose
c'est ces femmes et et l éduquer ou pas
alors on va dire ça dépend il faut pas
oublier que dans la france du xviie
siècle
la majorité des femmes vivent à la
campagne 90% la population qui gérera
exactement donc pour ces femmes-là un
accès à l'éducation qui va être limité
tout simplement d'abord à ce que leur
propre mère va leur transmettre donc sa
cellule
l'élément le plus important on va ouvrir
tout doucement en tout cas louis xiv m'a
encouragé à ce que l'on ouvre des écoles
dans toutes les paroisses
malheureusement ces suivis peu d'effet
tout simplement parce que même quand on
ouvre une école
eh bien on ouvre une école pour les
garçons et comme en fait ça coûte cher
de payer un maître une maîtresse bien on
va pas forcément accueillir les petites
filles à l'école et dans ces écoles
d'éducation elle était spécifique au
métier qu'on envisageait que la
demoiselle à l'honneur en fait puisque
ces écoles finalement vont beaucoup plus
fonctionner en ville et bien
effectivement en ville dans les
institutions qui sont ou payantes ou
gratuites
on va adapter l'enseignement donc si par
exemple vous êtes une fille d'artisans
et bien comme on sait que peut-être vous
serez amené à tenir la caisse
il faut que vous sachiez comptait donc
ça fait partie voilà des choses que l'on
enseigne en fonction et finalement de
votre destin donc ça c'était pour la
plupart des écoles mais madame de
maintenon a fait construire une école un
peu spéciale à saint cyr essentielle
écoles alors en fait à côté
effectivement de ces petites écoles il
ya les couvents et dans ces institutions
exceptionnel il y à l'établissement de
saint cyr une fondation royal puisque
louis xiv donne le terrain c'est là son
architecte jules hardouin mansart qui va
construire le bâtiment et saint cyr a
une fonction bien particulière puisque
louis xiv décide de d'ouvrir cet
établissement pour sa petite noblesse
celle qu'il sert régulièrement dans les
armées mais qui n'a pas toujours les
moyens d'éduquer ses enfants
et alors là quelle différence dans
l'éducation dispensée par rapport aux
écoles plus traditionnels aux écoles
urbaines et bien l'éducation va être
beaucoup plus poussée on apprend à lire
à écrire on apprend bien sûr le calcul
mais on apprend aussi l'histoire la
géographie on va pratiquer le théâtre
alors pas pour le plaisir qu'il procure
mais tout simplement parce que ces
jeunes filles viennent de province elles
ont parfois des accents et donc du coup
l'idée c'est qu'avec le théâtre on va
gommer ses accents catherine blondeau
vous auriez aimé vivre à cette époque
pas vraiment la grèce a effectivement la
présentation
ne laisse pas un rêveur mais je trouve
très intéressant de pouvoir montrer aux
nouvelles générations
le droit des femmes qui n'étaient pas
encore acquis à l'époque comme on peut
le voir mais je trouve ça très
intéressant de faire la passerelle entre
avant et maintenant c'est vrai que c'est
un thème qui a été un peu laissés pour
compte ces dernières années et qui
revient à l'étude
aujourd'hui thèmes qu'il ne faut pas
négliger alors forcément lorsque l'on
pense aux femmes dans l'entourage de
louis xiv on associe nécessairement
l'idée du pouvoir à tort ou à raison
alors à la fois oui parce que les femmes
sont présentes dans l'entourage roi dans
l'entourage royal par la reine et nous
aussi par la reine mère
anne d'autriche a été ré gens qu'il ne
faut pas l'oublier c'est à dire que
pendant quelques années elle a été à la
tête du royaume un royaume qui est l'un
des plus puissants en europe mais
al'inverse marie thérèse d'autriche est
une reine qui n'est rennes que parce
qu'elle est l'épousé du roi et qui n'a
pas de rôle politique spécifique
pas plus que n'en n'ont eu des
maîtresses alors là on désacralise
arrête mais man on s'attend à beaucoup
verte dans le secret de l'alcôve elle
fasse jouer leurs relations en réalité
il n'en est rien louis xiv prend soin de
séparer chaque pan de sa vie est en fait
les maîtresses n'ont pas de rôle réel
elles sont là
pour pour le plaisir du roi la reine
elle a une mission donner un héritier au
royaume et c'est vraiment le moment où
pour elle elle est reconnue rennes
d'ailleurs alors votre exposition elle
s'appuie également sur des lettres que
vous avez retrouvé qui provenaient de la
palatine
qu'est ce qu'elle disait alors la
palatine c'est la deuxième épouse de
monsieur monsieur c'est le frère du roi
et la palatine avait de la famille dans
toutes les cours européennes et elle
écrivait quotidiennement à aux membres
de sa famille et elle y décrit tout
l'avis de la cour à la fois ses propres
tracas personnel si souci en tant que
femme ses soucis en tant que maire pour
marier ses enfants elles décrivent les
événements importants et donc en fait
c'est une source très importante pour
connaître les femmes elles mêmes
regrette le fait d'être devenue madame
comprend que son père ait choisi de la
marier parce qu'ils ne savaient pas quoi
faire d'elle mais du coup c'est une
source très précieuse et surtout l allan
un langage exceptionnel truculent qui
vous fait rire presque à chaque page et
vous êtes également soucieux de ce qui
va pouvoir se passer pour ces enfants
vous disant mai mais la pauvre tout
simplement oui on est pris dans le
papier c'était beaucoup de contraintes
est ce que les femmes à l'époque
d'ailleurs travaillé aux côtés de leurs
maris ou alors le travail village une
nécessité vous l'avais dit la majorité
des femmes vivent à la campagne
donc pendant que l'homme est en train de
travailler dans les champs la femme elle
s'occupe de la maison du potager de
l'éducation des enfants va aller vendre
le surplus il suit du potager donc elle
est essentielle dans la vie du foyer et
en ville les femmes travaillent
légalement
est-ce qu'elles bénéficiaient des mêmes
conditions de travail alors c'est ce que
j'allais pas légalement juridiquement
les femmes sont exclues d'un certain
nombre de métiers mais dès lors qu'elles
sont les pousses de certains enfin les
pousses de certains hommes de métier eh
bien ce sont elles qui tiennent la
boutique qui accueille les clients et
qui donc travaillent aux côtés de l'art
marie et parfois même assure à la mort
de ce dernier
la transmission de la boutique à leurs
enfants très bien alors je sais que
avant de conclure vous vouliez nous
annoncer un spectacle qui aura lieu le
17 novembre mardi 17 novembre à 20h30 et
qui sera représentée par allah
compatible accompagné par dont il
festino alors ce spectacle nous a
beaucoup plu parce que justement on va
dire que c'est une autre moyen un autre
moyen de découvrir la condition des
femmes
c'est une compagnie qui met en scène un
comédien qui va réciter des textes à la
fois misogyne
d'autres au contraire presque féministe
et puis ce comédien est accompagné de
quelques musiciens et d'une chanteuse
qui interprète des airs de l'époque donc
c'est un autre moyen de vivre la
condition féminine du xviie siècle
au final est-ce qu'on veut dire que la
condition féminine a fait un bond en
avant a beaucoup évolué ou pas tant la
condition féminine a évolué forcément
suffisamment je pense qu'il ya encore du
chemin à faire
c'est bien probable à l'e sophie moreau
cathy blondeau merci d'avoir été parmi
nous aujourd'hui je rappelle que l'on
pourra retrouver
l'exposition être femme sous louis xiv
au musée promenade de marier le rôle ou
sienne jusqu'au 14 février et
l'exposition geneviève penloup à la
mezzanine de l'hôtel de ville de
guyancourt jusqu'au 31 octobre
nous poursuivons notre programme avec
une autre très belle exposition situé
cette fois ci à l'espace richaud de
versailles isola nova exposition
présentée jusqu'au 8 novembre
philippe calandre nous propose 16
photomontage dont venise imaginaire
entre documents et collages images de
patrick jacq du dixmude philippe
calandre au photographe d'origine pressé
mode a souhaité se distancier de la
réalité en recréant des images connu
pour ses photos montages de zones
industrielles
cet amateur d'architecturé propose une
nouvelle série de compositions autour
d'une venise onirique au fil des années
je me suis un petit peu lassé de
de la réalité j'ai décidé de
reconstruire ma propre réalité
en allant vers l'utopie
et bien cette photo de composition qui
part de plusieurs images de plusieurs
fragments je dirais avec cette ces
différents fragments j'ai géré composer
une image qui paraît être une véritable
image mais qui n'en est pas une à partir
de clichés de bâtiments réels réalisés à
venise avec un argentique philippe
calandre propose au bout d'un an de
travail cette composition photographique
deal fictives
ces images sont obtenus par photomontage
sur ordinateur avec toujours le souci de
respecter la direction de la lumière la
difficulté dans ses prises de vue était
de combiner deux types d'architecturés
opposé c'est à dire larchitecture de
venise traditionnel avec tout ce que
cela comporte
dans les ornements
et une autre architecture qui est celle
que l'on cache le plus souvent ils
architecture de porto marghera qui la
ville industrielle à proximité de venise
et le but était de joindre ses deux
architectures cette exposition présentée
à l'espace richaud de versailles
jusqu'au 8 novembre a été commandé
initialement par l'architecte jean
michel wilmotte pour sa fondation
vénitienne dans un tout autre genre
l'hôtel de ville de villepreux héberge
jusqu'au 7 novembre l'exposition le
ville provient et son animal l'occasion
pour l'association de photographes
villepreux images pixels de mettre en
scène dans le cadre de leur atelier les
villes prussiens et leurs animaux se
sont prêtés au jeu perroquet chat chien
poules lapins et leurs propriétaires
alors l'adage se vérifie t-il les
animaux ressemble utiles à leurs maîtres
n'hésitez pas à venir le découvrir on se
réunit au moins une fois par semaine et
ensuite on a différents ateliers
et puis en fait c'est un échange de
passionnés dont combien sur les
débutants on leur apprend à faire de la
photographie ont comme jeudi on est on
aiguise notre oeil puisque on analyse
des photos on organise des sorties on
couvre des événements que ce soit la
fête de la ville un événement sportif et
comme chaque semaine votre rubrique
cinéma
que pensez-vous des films à l'affiché
cette semaine vous avez au micro d'
elodie moines bon film que j'aime bien
frais le voir parce que ça sert à cours
d'histoire de d'un héros qui est qu'on
soupçonnait pas en plus en version
originale c'est impeccable
c'est un film magnifique avec des prises
de vues extraordinaires
on a une prise de conscience en fait
deux
de ce que ça représente de manière
scientifique et pour nous des
générations à venir
voit plein de choses qu'on connaissait
pas parce qu'il ne va pas forcément voir
la antarctique ça nous intéresse pas
parce pas forcément c'est un film très
dur mais je m'y attendais un peu mais
mais c'est aussi très très belle
histoire d'un film
prenant très bien mis en scène parce que
qu'ils reportent bien les tissement de
lampes esprit écologique et
l'interprétation des couples était extra
c'est un film qui commence durement mais
plus le temps avance plus on se retrouve
dans les comptes dans l'imaginaire et au
ca nous transporte
c'est extraordinaire c'est certainement
un des plus beaux films de science
fiction
est ce que c'est vraiment de la science
fiction d'ailleurs mais c'est très très
bien réalisé c c'est passionnant on
s'ennuie pas une seconde
cette semaine c'est cyril haddad de
l'espace noir et des clayes-sous-bois
qui nous donne son coup de coeur sur les
nouveautés à l'affiché cette semaine
notre coup de coeur et de dessins animés
mun le gardien de la lune réalisé par
benoît philippon et alexandre est
bouillant dans un monde fabuleux une
petit faune facétieux et désigné bien
malgré lui le gardien de levure celui
qui apporte la nuit et veille sur le
monde des rêves mais il enchaîne les
catastrophes et donne l'opportunité aux
gardiens des ténèbres de voler le soleil
avec l'aide de saône de fiers gardien du
soleil et la fragile du cir mule part
alors dans une quête extraordinaire qui
fera de lui un gardien de légende
ce film d'animation poétique vaut
vraiment le détour à la fois pour sa
belle histoire et son esthétique hors du
commun
il déborde d'inventivité en termes de
personnages
artistiquement le dessin animé se montre
au final assez singulier et imaginatif
il fera succomber un large public devant
le charme qu'il dégage ce divertissement
absolument féerique et diablement
efficace est un programme idéal pour une
vision familiale
il touchera à la fois petit écran côté
distribution nous retrouvons les voix de
omar sy de l'imitateur michael gregorio
ainsi que de celle d'izia isna
la lune je crois qu'il ya une méprise
nul a fait une terrible erreur en
choisissant cet imposteur
les plus grosses foires
payet l'échantillon des diablotins volet
soleil
il est toi qui devra gérer les
conséquences lune le gardien de la nuit
est à découvrir cette semaine en famille
à l'espace ce diplomate hier mardi 20
octobre le film jurassic world faisait
sa sortie nationale en dvd film dans
lequel je le rappelle notre yvelinois
omar sy interprète le rôle de bari pour
ceux qui n'auraient pas vu le film
extraits
ouais et avant de se quitter je vous
propose comme chaque semaine quelques
dates à noter de votre agenda culturel
vendredi 30 octobre l'ugc ciné cité de
skywest vous propose une soirée retour
vers le futur avec la projection des
trois opus de la trilogie culte de
robert zemeckis en vo sous titrée à
partir de 17h30
également mardi 3 novembre à 20 heures à
la salle jacques-brel de montigny le
bretonneux clownerie un spectacle
étonnant familiale où s'entremêlent
danse contemporaine et mime servi par
trois clowns
enfin mardi 3 novembre toujours à 20h30
au théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
scène nationale retrouvez la pièce de
théâtre notre peur de n'être pièce
signée par le jeune et talentueux auteur
et metteur en scène fabrice murgia pour
évoquer la solitude de l'homme moderne
à l'ère du virtuel fin du kiosque pour
cette semaine
émission à voir et à revoir sur notre
site internet pour ma part je vous
retrouverai la semaine prochaine
mercredi 28 octobre avec plaisir avec en
plateau le groupe gaz de ville pour
parler musique très bonne soirée à tous